- Today we are going to do an interview
and it's going to feature puppies!
Bring me the puppies!
(upbeat music)
Oh, yeah, there's the one. Come here, Red.
Look at Red, look at that face.
(squeaky voice) Hi, hi. Who has a toy?
Come back and play with me, though.
(laughs)
Okay, I have to ask the fans questions.
Let's see.
Are you gonna read it?
You gonna read it, Red?
You're stranded on a desert island,
oh, you're a hairdresser, huh?
You're stranded on a desert island.
Which of these people
you've worked with before
do you want with you?
Tyler Perry, Octavia Spencer,
Terrence Howard, or Brad Pitt?
I'm gonna go with Tyler Perry
because he has his own private jet.
Which one, which one?
You pick it, Sally.
You pick it, you pick it, you pick it.
What character have you
enjoyed playing the most
throughout your career and why?
I think I would have to say Vernell Watson
from Talk To Me because she was fly.
She was the seventies.
Oh, we have our next question.
The movie was set in the seventies
and I loved her wardrobe
and she was, she was the real cookie.
What's your biggest deal breaker
when it comes to relationships?
(laughs)
Chewing on the ears?
Lying, you can't lie to me.
If you do I'll turn into Melinda.
Oh, this was too long.
Whoever that is, I'm not
answering that. That's a paragraph
(screams) (laughs) You little cutie.
What is the craziest or scariest
thing that happened to you
on set while filming Acrimony?
These puppies right now.
They're attacking my weave, honey.
I guess the scariest thing
I had to do was to jump
in this pool, in the middle
wee hours of the night
or morning and (bleep)
Oop, that was another
movie! Next question!
Can you share one funny
or embarrassing fact
that most people don't
really know about you?
I'm kinda gassy.
Do you wanna come home with me?
Are you trying to come home with me?
What we gonna call you?
I gotta spend some time
with you for a sec.
Misty!
Misty, misty.
We have Red, we have Francie, and Misty!
Did I do good? I think I did good.
Can you figure out who's Red?
- The red one.
- Right. Can you figure out who's Misty?
- Um. The misty one.
- No.
- What were you doing,
are we doing an interview?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, in the fishbowl.
- In the fishbowl, okay.
- Look at Red, look at Red.
- Okay, so it says Acrimony has a lot
to do with being able to
truly let, look at these dogs.
Truly being able to let things go.
What advice do you have for someone
to be able to really just
move forward and move on?
- See, that's a great question for you.
- I would tell people that if you spend
so much time in your life looking back,
you can't get to what's in front of you
and you can't get to what's ahead of you.
Because you miss the great things that are
(laughs) waiting for you by looking
(laughs) you miss the great things.
- Just move on, honey, like
these puppies. They moving on.
- Just move on, just move on.
- Just move on.
What are some the weirdest jobs you had
before becoming an actress? (laughs)
I was a singing/dancing waitress.
- Come here. - I wouldn't
call that really weird
because I was a.
- A singing/dancing waitress?
- Yeah, on a river boat.
- On a river boat.
- ♪ Left a good job. ♪
- Proud Mary?
Proud Mary.
(laughter)
I knew it, I knew it.
(beep)
♪ Big wheels keep on turnin', ♪
♪ Proud Mary keep on burnin'. ♪
♪ And we're rollin'. ♪
- Oh, it's not that part yet.
- No, not (laughs)
- I got this hair, I got this hair, honey!
I got this hair, honey!
- Okay, okay.
What's this.
(laughter)
Which celebrity makes you laugh the most?
(laughs) Kevin Hart.
- Ooooh. Cliché.
- Cliché.
- I love Kevin Hart.
- All of these puppies
are available for adoption
at North Shore Animal League of America.
Adopt, adopt. Don't shop, adopt.
- And their faces are beautiful.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And their eyes
- And Taraji's taking all four home.
- You know how much I travel.
I don't have a private jet.
You gonna help me with that, Mr. Perry?
Get this on.
- And we're done.
Thank you.
- No no no! Keep recording.
(laughter)
(upbeat music)